I can't believe she kicked that welcome
to another episode of natural deep with
grace Helbig do you know what that is
you're an idiot just kidding you dumb
just kidding you're beautiful holy
stupid not too deep of grace topic is my
new audio video podcast how does that
work well here I'm gonna be showing you
snippets of the interview that I do with
my youtube friend guess and then you can
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud and
search not too deep with grace Helbig
subscribe to the podcast listen to the
full interview in its entirety and then
you can come back here and watch as my
guest and I enjoy a my take on a really
stupid YouTube challenge this week's
guests rhett and Link you happy you
feeling ok I'm happy why I tend to not
be okay that's too deep welcome to not
too deep with grace Helbig for you guys
personally any changes coming up to your
personal hair I'm thinking about doing
the dip and what I mean but is like a
soft-serve cone is dipped in chocolate
like the swirl no just that you've been
to Dairy Queen before yes flurries all
day no I'm talking about dipping my head
into a vat of chocolate I didn't like
crackle yep oh yeah I know I'm saying so
it'll look exactly the same it'll be
brown and edible what's in store for
your hair I constantly look at myself in
the mirror and think should I change
this yeah this is a little too
ridiculous do you think that jennifer
Love Hewitt takes dumps quietly you know
it's funny because I've thought about
this a lot take dumps quietly so we're
not talking about smell at all it's just
totally you're just concerned about
volume yes well I do know that she likes
to be called loved by my friends really
well so somebody who'd like to be called
loved by friends I would think would
like to be silent while crapping
Pez waz wants to know have you ever
tried to impersonate each other for the
day could you do an impersonation of
each other I don't think my ego could
handle impersonating him for a day like
maybe two minutes could you do a like a
10-second impersonation right now did
you know that criminals formed
pineapples and that there are fingertips
disappeared Wow I don't like a mr.
Rogers character here I'll even give you
a it's putting the glasses on whoa
instant game changer I have a headache
welcome to your this is a take on the
cotton ball challenge which you guys I'm
sure have seen on YouTube yes yes except
we will be playing the cotton balls
challenge each one of us will be red cap
with double stick tape on it and one at
a time we're gonna have one minute to
blindfold Lee get as many cotton balls
onto our head as possible to recreate
our hair okay and whoever it is the most
amount of cotton balls is the winner so
the first things first is we need to all
situate our bald cap have you tested
this out guaranteed sale goes grace you
look like and now you see why don't do
the buzzing over you or they call that
skin mullet oh so now you just take a
roll of double stick tape now what does
a double stick tape do the double stick
tape is gonna be how we get the cotton
balls to stick to our head yeah give me
good
give me good luck
I feel of a Philemon montage come
[Music]
one at a time one at a time I'm gonna
set the timer for a minute you have this
[Music]
yeah I wish I knew it was so funny
I really sit in the bar somewhere
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh winner winner chicken dinner not yet
though it's my turn now
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're gonna let you guys all vote
okay so see who you guys think got more
taken good things writ no link Oh Rick I
think me I think I was ranked one oh my
god you got kid bring it buddy
okay I was
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you rattling for being here and
participating in the cotton balls
challenge they're out make sure to go
over to iTunes and check out the full
interview with written Lincoln not too
deep with grace Helbig and go subscribe
to their channel again you too because
they're just cool people wonder twins
triplets well there you go that's a
podcast with rhett and Link they were
wonderful wonderful guests make sure
that you go over to iTunes or SoundCloud
or click the link down in the
description box below to go subscribe to
the full
audio version of the podcast and then
you can listen to it and then you can
feel like you're part of something see
you next time I know
[Music]